I cannot be more grateful to you for
tuning in subscribing and especially for
commenting and leaving questions that
you'd like me to answer as we reached
this historic milestone in our journey
to reach a million Minds we're over six
of the way there hello and welcome to a
very special episode of the into the
impossible podcast TI I your formerly
fearful host Dr Brian keing today we're
recording a very special episode this is
our
150,000 subscriber celebration
subscribtion today we're going to take
questions from Twitter Instagram and
YouTube of course where you're watching
this and the podcast audience can reach
me at briank king.com
podcast to also leave voice messages we
had a couple of those get to those and
we'll get into it on our way up the
ladder of success together
where you are enabling This
Magnificent fun mischievous mission that
we have embarked upon for the past three
years it's hard to believe it's been
three years it's taken a lot of time
maybe we're hitting a hockey stick type
inflection point maybe not time will
tell maybe uh we'll see but since the
time that I requested comments and
questions on August 17th to today which
is September 17th
uh we received an additional 12,000
subscribers so it's pretty cool uh to
see that rate of growth and if it keeps
up T-Series Mr Beast black Nastia watch
out I've got you on my sit so thanks
again let's get into it all together the
150,000 subscribers
celebration
here we go first questions I will take
will come from
Twitter so Twitter is now known as X and
it wasn't the last time I did one of
these specials back in uh it was only a
couple months ago we hit our 100,000th
subscriber and it's just so gratifying
to see that so first couple of questions
will come from Twitter and uh I invite
you to follow me there and ask away Dr
Brian keading on Twitter on Instagram or
other people are uh leaving comments as
well first question comes from a
longtime friend of the show Dr Leonard
Mumy I hope I'm pronouncing your name
right Leonard he asked me what has been
my favorite scientific paper I guess
this could be interpreted as paper I've
read or paper I've
written I suppose in the latter category
paper I've written my first paper came
out in
1997 that's written over about two years
from 1995 to
1996 as a graduate student started off I
was at Brown University and I ended up
writing a lot of the paper in the UK in
London with my great mentor Dr Alex pev
who I had the honor of inviting to my
Royal Institution talk and you should be
able to see the Royal Institution
discourse I got to do back on June 29th
that should be out by the time this
video comes out if not Subs subribe to
their Channel and you'll see it I'm very
very proud of that talk and having him
in the audience and you'll see a picture
of him uh so that paper was called the
feasibility of detecting the large
angular scale polarization of the cosmic
microwave background
radiation uh so you know doesn't exactly
fit into a tweet or a post uh
nevertheless it was uh kind of preent in
many ways mainly thanks to Alex and my
co-authors including my PhD adviser
Peter timby I'm still very close with at
University of Wisconsin Madison and this
was laying out what it would take to
detect the polarization of the CMB for
the first time back in late 90s well it
was never it wasn't detected until the
early 2000s when uh the daisy experiment
um ended up making the first detection
but the actual focus of that particular
paper was on detecting gravitational
waves in the CMB and of course we
thought we did that in 2014 a mere 18
years later uh and of course that was
later retracted uh but all of that stemm
from this very first paper that I ever
wrote uh the laying out what it would
take to detect the polarization of the
CNB and later the detection of the
gravitational waves only became really
the major pursuit of my career and has
maintained that although branching out
into many other fields including radio
astronomy and infrared
astronomy but still that is the main
focus of the uh of the Simon Observatory
which is going to be the the Legacy
project uh that I'm so blessed to be a
part of and to co-lead with my friends
and collaborators so thank you Leonard
that's really great Amanda
Johnstone who I believe I met on
clubhouse if you remember Clubhouse rip
Amanda used to host these amazing
intellectual uh kind of salons where
intellectuals would gather and sometimes
she'd bring me up to talk about
cosmology and
astronomy and she asked me what was what
was the moment you realize you think
differently to most I think I've always
been a little bit of a uh of an iconic
classtic you know driven person I
wouldn't say I Rise to that level yet
maybe ever but the point I've always
wanted to do something important I've
always wanted to isue the kind of
mainstream and and uh you know cheap or
or fast Thrills and and Li of more
enduring Pursuits uh such as the life of
the mind or deep relationship ships with
family and
children and I believe that you know the
kind of focus I had I never did any
alcohol drugs anything like that in high
school still I've never done a drug an
illegal drug and I hope I can maintain
that you know for the rest of my life
and that was always very different
people were getting drunk in high school
and college doing drugs I never wanted
to do that I always felt like the brain
was so precious and I didn't want to
Monkey around with the circuitry I was
only a lot of a mere handful of IQ
points and I didn't want to take those
for granted and I still feel that way
and I advise my children that too um you
know a lot of parents have done I'm not
judging a lot of my friends did it and I
was always a designated driver in high
school while they you know I shered them
around on dates uh pretty miserable
experience for a part of high school but
I still am very close with a lot of my
high school friends that are probably
watching this video and you know who you
are uh they're part of my Council of
Elders that I rely on for wisdom and
advice so I think I always wanted to
live a deep life and do meaningful
things I had a job since I was 12 years
old I wanted to be independent have
money and um acquire skills and
resources to be the best intellect I
could be knowing that you know going
into Academia wasn't necessarily a path
to riches but it was a path to doing
something in the footsteps of my great
Heroes of that time Isaac azimoff and
Carl Sean and uh and many others who
influenced me to a scholar or astronomer
Professor eventually although I never
thought I could be one because the odds
are so low that anybody gets into the uh
uh professorate U as it is is almost a
miracle and I never take it for granted
so I think for me the you know it was
always instilled in me by my parents to
to pursue deep things not shallow things
for me that was understanding the origin
of the universe which led me to question
the biggest Topics in philosophy and
theology religion and certainly in
fundamental physics and cosmology which
has been my passion and my uh my
vocation uh ever since okay again on
Twitter Dr bran keing Omar gafar writes
why were you so dismissive of the UAP
issue on Joe Rogan do you not think it's
wise for scientists to step aside and
let the lawyers politicians and other
investigators do their job here and
figure out what's going on so that
scientists can get actual
data I see a problem with scientist
apping on this prematurely and
negatively and it's a constant theme
that causes problems with this issues
particularly in light of where we are
right now Omar I you know I'm
sympathetic to always being um you know
let me let me phrase it this way to not
being dismissive I don't think I was
dismissive I think I'm reflecting my
actual perspective based on evidence
based on data that I've seen and none of
the evidence Rises to the level of um of
you know constituting proof for me and
for many many of my friends you you have
to realize even though I do come across
because I am uh pessimistic about the
notion of not only extraterrestrial life
but extraterrestrial intelligent life
that's visiting the Earth I'm extremely
skeptical about that I still believe
there's a there's you know on one by any
measure there's a huge probability that
I could be wrong and I think that's
important to acknowledge on the other
hand I think leaving to lawyers I mean
you know no offense if you're a lawyer
or a politician Omar but leaving it to
lawyers and politicians is is kind of
maybe some of the worst cohorts to leave
it to I would I would prefer if you said
leave it to the military eyewitnesses
and so forth but you didn't so I'm just
addressing what you said and I don't
think it's a purview at all of
politicians I think politicians have
obfuscated many many things and if there
were indeed alien technology and
intelligence is visiting the United
States um for example they would be the
first to use it to their own particular
purposes where politicians desire is to
acquire power and resources from the
people that they're supposed to be
serving but often times they act as if
they're monarchic you know uh
authoritarians and I think that's very
dangerous so I see no no need and I
think a scientist if a scientist can't
Aline let alone collect the data on uh
aspects of astrophysics um propulsion
engineering time travel uh dimensional
you know modification and so forth who
is going to do that exactly a lawyer you
know Joe Biden um now be that as it may
I've also been influenced by people such
as David spurgle and and others and the
people I've interviewed on the into the
impossible podcast including the pilots
and I've spoken to many of the people
that claim that they've eyewitnessed
things so I it's coming from a position
not of dismissiveness at all in fact
I've said many times I'd be the most you
know joyous you know ecstatic person
among that cohort to know that we are
not alone I just don't believe that the
evidence we have currently Rises to a
cintilla of proof that we are being
visited by UFOs um from Advanced
extraterrestrial technology and I've
spoken about that a lot so no I think we
need more data I've had on the foremost
private you know individual and that's
Avi lobe I've had on David spurgle who
led the NASA report hope to have Shelley
Wright who is one of the contributors to
the NASA report these are people that
are advocating for more and more data
from uh different uh media platforms or
shall I say sensor platforms from space
from the ground from the military from
civilians and aob of course the galloo
project which I used to advise and just
didn't have the time and and did feel
like it was a little bit of a conflict
of interest because I do remain
skeptical about the base layer of
reality which would require a uh alien
life to exist in the universe so I'm
skeptical about that let alone the
technology that could be proferred by
them Nico grunenberg says he was not
suspicious as dismissive as much as I
thought he was but rather neutral in
making arguments why we shouldn't fall
victim to Authority bias yeah that's
exactly right Nico Dr Kitty made an
argument I hadn't considered regarding
the story of how in World War II the
Allies could spoof radar so yes I did do
um that was kind of spur of the moment
but it did come to me this anecdote
about Lou Alvarez Nobel prizewinning
scientist depicted in the movie
Oppenheimer um who's at Berkeley
co-discoverer with his son of uh one of
the leading theories of how um the
dinosaurs were uh
extincted uh it's called the KT boundary
and uh various types of deposits in the
Earth's crust that indicate this was a
meteor
impact and he uh did provide a a tool
that was used to spoof the German radar
sets by basically tricking the uh Axis
Powers the Germans into thinking that
Allied bombers were moving away from
them and in fact they were moving closer
so that their sensors would have
indicated complete violation of the laws
of physics that they were in evading the
inverse uh you know Square law uh and
instead getting closer even though their
signals were getting weaker so how could
that possibly reconciled well it was
beyond the understanding of the laws of
physics how something could do that and
in fact you would have ascribed perhaps
super luminal motion to these objects
because if you think that something's
you know uh 200 miles away and it's
actually two miles away and your sensor
indicates that in you know a fraction of
a th millisecond then uh then these
objects would be apparently moving much
faster than the speed of light so that's
just one example of how we hear this and
of course my friend Eric uh Weinstein
has mentioned this many many times you
know that if if we believe these things
are moving and violating the laws of
physics then we should have more
physicists involved in this not fewer
and I think I uh certainly do agree with
Eric's sentiment back to Twitter
questions Artisan Tony says will we
survive the
woo I don't know Tony I'll say
yes um I'll say yes we will survive the
woo okay dollar sign papa. Mass ask the
question assuming Eric Weinstein's
geometric Unity model is correct and
distances in space and time are fungible
why don't you believe extraterrestrials
have been to Earth well quite frankly we
don't have evidence that Eric's model is
correct or any model that could allow
for diens interdimensional travel I've
had one Mal Thea on um he talked about
anti- Deiter space and that could be
another way to instantiate wormholes
that could be traversable even by human
beings meaning that they would have a
diameter greater than a meter um uh and
yet we don't live in anti- desitter
space we live in desitter space so um
none of these models for uh a
unification of gravity or of forces have
been have been um have been established
with any degree of of credibility
including Erics doesn't mean that
they're not plausible they don't have
things that are interesting to study and
I keep trying to pursue these with austo
to try to provide an experimental um
data that could validate or inv validate
them I mean don't forget a job of an
experimentalist is not to prove a theory
it's to invalidate every other Theory
and that's what we hopefully are doing
with our projects including things like
the Simon array and Simon's Observatory
and we're you know imminently about to
get first light data from the Simon
Observatory and we have incredible data
already from the Simon array and these
are really as I stressed in my answer to
Amanda's question earlier these are
predicated on my desire to only want to
study the Deep most foundational
questions in what's called fundamental
or Elementary physics that includes
particles forces fields and the
evolution of the early
Universe okay Dr Tamara
Som uh asks how does your spiritual
views I believe you have one based on
your website I don't know on my website
necessarily but how do they influence
your approach to being a scientist and
to doing science thanks Dr Kitty thank
you Tamar well um I am uh a religious I
do practice relig
spirituality is kind of a woo word that
maybe an Artis Tony was referring to um
spirituality is is kind of a a very a
very strange term for me to identify
with it I don't mean to say it in a
negative sense you yourself Are
Spiritual I just mean that I am driven
by more by uh I would say I'm a
behaviorist that I believe that your
behavior influences your your mind your
mentality your
psychology your brain can control your
body and vice versa so um I believe in
searching for evidence and of course you
know if we had evidence for God you
wouldn't have the notion for Faith
everybody would just believe in God and
say just belief like I don't say I
believe in gravity I have evidence for
Gravity so it influences the pursuit and
you I just gave a talk it was just my
birthday I did my bar mitzvah in um in
Israel at the cotel at the Western Wall
uh that was a highlight experience for
me I think that deserves some some sound
effects so if your ears are sensitive to
sound effects um too bad here we go
we're going to do party
noises there we go there's a blowing
Horn uh trumpet
Bell that was roll and last but not
least my favorite that always makes me
laugh the DJ airhorn for the bar mitzvah
um and I did it at the Western Wall and
there's of course a great Yeshiva there
called as at Torah which in Hebrew means
the fire of Torah the fire of the Old
Testament and was very uh it was very a
inspiring to me to be there I wouldn't
say I had a spiritual experience being
there you know it's the remnants of the
of the second second temple which is
destroyed in 2,000 years ago a lot of
people do they put little notes in the
wall and no that's not the Western wall
behind me over here in my Mountain
Hideway where I like to record these
q&as it was very special to me to be in
this place of great Holiness to three
world religions Islam Christianity and
Judaism and yet I didn't feel you know
overwhelming presence of God even though
I was lecturing about it and so for me
God is an
intellectual um Pursuit it's something
that you can never really approach with
an understanding that you could say I
believe in God um as Jordan Peterson has
become a friend says you know who is a
man to say he believes in God like this
God need Brian Kings you know like uh
approbation uh I I think it's um I think
it's an example of huus that we say well
I believe in God well good that doesn't
tell me anything about you what do you
do what is your practice what how does
your belief in God alter your behavior
or not alter your behavior that's fine
too and as I talked about Peter bazian
Michael Shermer these are noted atheists
Michael Lawrence Krauss I love talking
to these people but the by the same
token I feel like religious people have
an obligation to learn more science and
scientific people shouldn't really
comment like Lawrence knows almost
nothing about Judaism and that's because
he has a block again he doesn't want to
learn about it he learned last about
Judaism when he was 12 years old
preparing for his bar mitua and he's you
know 20 years older than me so this is a
long time ago and I feel like they
stopped learning at that age they would
never take the um disproof of a of a
mathematical iCal or um physics proof
from a 12-year-old and yet they will do
it from their 12-year-old self to refute
any belief in God and they'll be a
couple questions later on you'll see
more about religionspiritual thanks
again okay awesome posum asks are we
parentheses humans thanks not possums a
solution to ferm's Paradox is DNA
engineered by an alien civilization to
colonize the Galaxy I know it doesn't
answer any deep questions but it's kind
of interesting specific spefically given
that a lot of controversy exists
regarding origins of life on Earth well
you know I think DNA engineering is an
interesting concept you'd have to ask
well who you know who engineered the DNA
who or what um you know I've talked to
many many people from Jamie green to
Carl Zimmer and uh Eric kersen bam and
many other people and it's just clear we
have no real strong notion for the
origin of life in the universe we have a
certain concepts of how life could have
originated elsewhere and come to the
Earth Pans spermic uh Origins as Fred
Hoy would call it but you know DNA is
pretty interesting because it does seem
to be a type of you know code technology
you know software code in a sense um you
know that if you say it was engineered
you have to ask well what's engineering
it but let's leave that aside it is kind
of like a time capsule it is the
ultimate time capsu the ultimate storage
machine doesn't require batteries you
know there's this Kevin Kelly works on
this long now Foundation this 10,000
year clock that's nothing I mean
compared to even you know the DNA that
we found from neanderthals or uh
dinosaur you know remnants of these
things so it's just incredible to think
how persistent how self resilient these
DNA structures are how they
self-perpetuate and store
copy transmit get modified but are you
know error
correcting it it does almost seem like a
magical technological invention and then
uh so the answer the solution ferm's
Paradox would be that the aliens you
know colonized us so we are them the
answer to ferm's question is that
they're here they're us they made us or
perhaps you know uh they're still here
and of and other people like Paul Davies
who I'm going to be hosting in a few
months back here at San
Diego you know as proposed there might
even be a shadow biosphere there might
not even be aliens here using different
types of DNA that our assays cannot
really interact with so we are ignorant
of their
existence um again speculation it is a
potential solution there's a book I've
started reading called like 75 solutions
to the fermes Paradox um and um I have
to check in there to see if that's one
of the potential resolutions of ferm's
paradox okay
christop
Christoper uh asks on Twitter is it
possible given the evidence that humans
have been Advanced on this planet way
longer than we thought not really sure I
mean humans are uh if we consider them
as Homo sapiens they certainly haven't
been here longer at least you know the
evidence and the fossil record um
technological record remember you can
date things in many many ways you don't
just need carbon for
but um but what we have dated things in
neanderthals prior to that and
homohabilis and um uh you know going
back to the you know three or four
million years ago in Africa uh those are
pretty Advanced primates but not of the
homo sapien uh genus and species so um
is it possible that there were evidence
that there's evidence for well the lack
of evidence doesn't prove that they
weren't here it's very there very few
bones and um and and you know tools and
things found it doesn't mean that before
we found them we would have thought that
man was maybe only 10,000 years old uh
and that's certainly disproven by the
fossil record so will we find things
that indicate that homo sapiens actually
have a longer Legacy on Earth perhaps um
but we don't have that now Christopher
bentti
funio if SpaceTime is curved by even in
an infinitly small amount might standing
gravitational waves exist well okay so
this is borrowing a concept from
electromagnetism or even from standing
waves and water waves or r on ropes
called the standing wave where you can
have a persistent oscillation which has
um the appearance of what's called a
standing wave a constant pattern even
though of course the air molecules are
moving inside of an organ pipe where
these types of phenomenon exist or if
you have a rope and you wave it up and
down just the right frequency uh you're
actually sending cancelling
and interfering um constructively and
destructively waves and opposite phase
velocities and so that can lead to
standing waves and ropes and
electromagnetic uh sit that's how your
microwave has a certain standing wave
pattern now there's not stationary the
electromagnetic fields are oscillating
at you know 10 to the 9th or higher
Hertz in the case of microwaves in a
microwave oven but um so you don't even
need a small electromagnetic field those
could be large electromagnetic fields uh
standing gravitational waves you'd have
to find a solution where there's a
boundary condition that is stable so in
a microwave oven the boundaries are the
metallic walls of the microwave that pin
the electromagnetic field to zero at
those um at those spatial extents
similar holding a rope or an organ pipe
with uh with um air uh density waves
standing within it so you need some
stationary pattern and the problem with
gravitational waves is that when you
have them generated they can only be
generated from moving sources um sources
that uh have dynamical what quadripolar
moments that vary in
time so it's not probable uh doesn't
mean it's not possible and a lot of the
electromagnetic wave um behaviors do
propagate uh no pun intended to
gravitational waves so it's not you know
totally crazy idea thank you bation okay
fa asked he doesn't ask he just says
well done sir you have a quality show
from one humble opinion thank you so
much I love to hear those kinds of
comments and questions so uh I won't say
this person's name because he's kind of
annoying um he is claiming that he is
talking to Einstein while I am a loser
with Fame uh just to let you know I do
get an awful lot of hateful uh you know
weird strange people on Twitter I try
not to block I don't think I've ever
blocked an actual follower even though
there are many many people that have
tried to bait me and say mean nasty
things about me or my friends I think
blocking should be reserved for the kind
of most egregious people and and some of
the people have said egregious stuff
it's just not about me they're just
obviously crazy individuals who are
chemically imbalanced um I don't know if
this person is it's very strange it's
contacted me many times um and uh just
to let you know uh those that aspire to
produce things in the public eye will
always find you know people that are
trying to take them down that dislike
them uh maybe even hate them even though
they've never met me and uh it's sad but
uh I'm trying to do the best I can to
communicate the cool stuff that I get
paid to do and learn about uh to you who
pay my salary many of you at least if
you're in the US or California
especially as a public University
employee so um yeah it's not all uh the
sunshine and and Roses although comments
like the next one are F fantastic here's
the next one uh Barry straw says
congrats on the Milestone my question to
you how do you like the media side of
things the physical clicking of virtual
buttons and media tools your favorite
apps and programs and favorite Tools in
your line of work physical and software
I'm gonna answer this a different way
I'm goingon to tell you the podcast that
I listen to on my iPhone uh which is
somewhere around here I listen to a lot
of weird podcasts that you might not
think about a lot of business podcast
I like a lot of productivity podcast and
YouTube channels uh and some of them
influence me and have helped me grow and
and thought about um new ideas new tools
the tools I I do enjoy you know kind of
the beinging in front of microphone it's
taken me a long time to get comfortable
doing one of these where I'm just
talking to you which is really just
recording and I'm not physically having
a conversation with somebody it's kind
of strange uh asking you know it's kind
of like community communicating with an
alien civilization not calling you guys
aliens but calling you intelligent you
know the soonest you could get a
response is you know round trip time is
eight years if it's on proximus Sor B so
um so you have to be comfortable kind of
talking into the ether and that's is no
different so I do love tools I I
probably have an addiction to my iPhone
use it many many hours a day and various
apps on it X Instagram YouTube Studio I
love uh replying comments there and
you'll find out more comment replies in
just a minute so I do a lot of that
watch a lot of YouTube um channels I
enjoy uh that have really benefited me
uh in part because they're so different
from what I do uh podcasts like Tim
Ferris I listen to it's very different
from what I do he's taught me a lot
about interviewing and um and you know
Peak performers and and and I could
probably do a much better job than I do
um other podcast one's called my first
million uh with two Tech Bros uh they're
just kind of have a fun Rapport and they
get along great and uh I like to listen
to them totally out of um the uh the
realm of what I do similarly uh I
listened to for the last probably the
longest podcast I've ever listened to is
one called Mac break weekly with Leo
leaport that's been going on like the
early
2000s um it's on video comes out every
Tuesday they have a great Rapport no pun
intend Leo laort uh learn about Le Mac
tricks and tools and you know become a
Mac addict in in a lot of ways it's just
so easy and seamless of course my friend
Lex fredman Joe Rogan I listen to them
Jordan Peterson less the you know less
so Jordan just he's very much involved
with um you know culture wars and
politics and and I do listen to Ben
Shapiro uh pretty regularly pretty much
every day Dennis Prager is another one I
listen to on the right side of the
spectrum on the left side of the
spectrum I listen to Caris swisser um
and uh Scott Galloway uh who's the only
person you know really who I've been you
know kind of annoyed with who didn't
come on the podcast even though he
agreed at least to come on with James
aliter that he'd come on never responded
to any of my emails so Scott if you're
out there that's not cool you had this
wonderful you know message that went
viral when you had a student show up 15
minutes late to your class once and you
just took them down and and uh you know
you're doing it for his own good well
the same thing happens you know in the
podcasting world you know I've had 17
Nobel Prize winners on the show not once
did they ever fail to write me back even
the ones that didn't come on um so it's
just uh come on buddy you know let's uh
let's uh get our acts together
especially when it comes to you know
giving back to the University of
California which you've given a lot of
money to but um you know this is the
biggest podcast in the history of the
University of California and you're a
native son so uh respond to an email or
two it would be a classy thing to do
other than that uh tools and t i I
listen to Sam Harris's waking up app I
don't care for him politically um I
think he's really gone off the deep end
but I give him my money and he does
great work in meditation space and I'm
not that great at it um but it's
something I can uh you know kind of
adhere two where it's using technology
it's using my phone I'm listening to
something I'm learning from all these
great individuals and speakers that he
has on um uh Ryan holiday again you know
he's a past guest on the show we don't
really agree politically on uh as much
he's another person who's you know kind
of gone off on the Trump anti-trump
anti- uh you know kind of uh Republican
sign of things and so I think it's um uh
you know kind of incumbent upon people
to to listen to people they don't agree
with and I do that a lot because there's
a lot more media out there you know to
consume than I can actually produce so
thank you for that question Barry okay
Estonian R Estonian who are your role
models growing up and in your
professional life that's an awesome
question so um even though my father was
a professor he was never really around
growing up so he wasn't a role model to
me at all and so I had to really get
those um role models from well my mother
and my older brother but also from books
and reading now know this is pre-
interet preg Google uh and the ones that
really spoke loudest to me have been
people like Galileo and Isaac azimoff
and Carl Sean and uh really proud to say
I was able to follow a little bit in
their footsteps to whatever extent I've
been able to and that is to write books
and communicate with the public like
they have done and I think that's a way
to give back Carl Sean said a book is
proof that humans can work work magic
because you have this long dead author
speaking in your ear uh teaching uh
things and you're participating actively
in learning well you know I'm still
alive thank God and hopefully it'll be
for a long time but um but I'm writing
books but I'm also doing podcasts you
can actually hear my voice you know I
don't think he did he did there are a
lot of videos of him uh of Carl and I'm
proud to say I had his daughter Sasha on
the podcast and his widow Andrian uh on
the podcast and we talked about contact
and all these cool things it was uh
quite a treat to to actually write books
and you know kind of have a little bit
of their intellectual DNA uh sprinkled
throughout the writing process that um
you know I hope to continue and
hopefully Inspire other people to do
someday okay K uh K or key asked what is
a practicing agnostic and do you include
the Multiverse and Spider-Man well a
practicing agnostic is to be you know
distinguished from a atheist um who
doesn't go to church or synagogue or
mosque and a practicing agnostic is
someone who does go to those things but
doesn't necessarily believe it's
knowable whether or not God exists so
that's agnostic it's not knowable that's
what it means um but if you don't go to
church you know what that really
distinguishes you as an agnostic
self-proclaimed agnostic which is only
self- declarable so but how a behavior
is look at you and saying that you're
behaving are you acting like an atheist
are your actual practices you know do
you you know just for whatever you know
do you violate the Ten Commandments um
that's just that's not the ultimate you
know Arbiter of of good or evil or
spirituality or atheism but it is a
standard right so you may say well I
don't kill people you know I don't steal
I don't uh bear false witness but um but
do you though and and what does it mean
to bear false witness what does it mean
to steal like does it really mean that
you only don't steal you know an I you
know iPhone from a store you know break
into a you know to a Nordstroms and and
pill for a sweater you know is that all
that stealing entails or do you you ever
like steal a joke or steal an idea not
give credit to something uh that influen
you that's actually considered a big sin
in Judaism it's considered gabas die
it's stealing thoughts stealing making
somebody think that you are doing
something when is actually either the
opposite of your intention or just
completely unintentional a good example
I've heard is you say my friend Amanda
invites me to her wedding in Australia I
actually don't know if she's married or
not um but let's say she does and I I'm
like ah I'm not able to go but um but uh
you know I don't get back to her I don't
even RSVP I'm just kind of a jerk and
then I happen to get invited to go down
to see you know to give a talk uh you
know with my friend uh Luke Barnes or
garrant Lewis or um or Brian Schmidt and
I'm down there and I'm at their
universities and I'm giving a talk and
then Amanda walks by she's oh Brian
you're just the best I'm so so glad that
you're here you came from my wedding uh
it's just so wonderful and and I'm if I
say
yeah I wouldn't have missed it for the
world didn't you get my RSVP you know
that seems like innocent you're not
really you know you don't want to hurt
their feeling no I'm actually here to
talk to somebody else in Australia um
showed up here just a coincidence and
you know it's hard to say that but then
think someday if like you you know my my
kid's gonna have his bar mitzvah and
then I invite her and then she feels all
this pressure because Brian you know
came flew all the way just to see me
just to come to my special day that's a
form of theft like you're you're
tricking somebody you should be honest
uh it's very very hard to do and I'm not
saying I'm you know innocent all the
time with perfectly Clean Hands but
being a practicing agnostic means that
I'm searching for answers I'm searching
to see if God you know if there's
evidence for God can I approach God but
I'm doing so within a framework a
framework that's Guided by the wisdom of
thousands of years of tradition and I'm
not advocating Judaism exclusively I'm
saying you should find a faith tradition
maybe the one you were born into
although that could be an accident you
know according to Richard
Dawkins you know no one is a born
Christian you know because Christian is
a belief-based faith which is true but I
think he's saying it you know to kind of
denigrate parents who rais their kids
Christian rather than to say
intellectually it's it's a true fact
that you know can't be born believing
something as a as a you know one day old
child nevertheless nevertheless I do
think it is important to have some form
of practice where you do think about and
distinguish yourself from a pure atheist
if you're going to call yourself an
agnostic otherwise it's just pure you
know purely it may mean something to you
but it won't mean something to anybody
else and you won't certainly be able to
influence people to kind of persuade
people whether you know religion is
their cup of tea or not that there's any
distinction between what you're doing
and doing you know strictly doing
nothing and again not with a value
judgment just stating a fact most
atheists don't do anything and then most
agnostics including the first guest on
the podcast Freeman Dyson I asked him
you know do you go to church no but you
call yourself an agnostic and you know
he had to think about it so you go back
and listen to or watch that episode to
get his uh reply I skipped one from
Gonzalo Chavez can you invite someone
from the following UFO offices in South
America probably not I don't know what a
UFO office is um he says because of that
you can then stop debating whether UFOs
exist you're able to show your audience
imagery and discoveries made by
countries um so there's a lot to unpack
there I have enough trouble staying on
top of what NASA the dod the Pentagon
the pilots that I interview the pilots
who I've T talked to but haven't had on
the show yet um there's a lot of
information out there and I don't think
it's you know fair to say that these are
the you know kind of Standards the
sinquin non are the
dfaa in Peru or the sfaa in Chile um I'm
not opposed to it but I'm not going to
make a lot of effort to go and and talk
to these people in a language I don't
understand um you know with various
types of data that I don't understand
either that said you know it would
certainly be interested if people do
contact me and I do get a lot of people
reaching out and I thank you I just
can't host every single person that you
know has a sighting or eyewitness you
know to be on the
podcast okay recr Moran lemiscate do you
have any comments or thoughts on
potential superc conductive interactions
in space and he has an a paper from the
proceedings of National Academy Sciences
about superc conductivity found in
meteorites and in fact I believe I'm
clicking on the link now uh yes it was
written by uh two of my colleagues markk
teans and Ivan Schuler this is super
connectivity found meteorites yes I did
talk to them about that it's fascinating
Discovery and super conductivity can be
found in nature um and in fact the first
elements to be found that we superc
conducting are just pure elements like
lead so those are certainly found in
space but these are more exotic ones and
different phases and environments and so
it's a fascinating discovery made by
Ivan Schuler and Mark teeman my two
friends and colleagues here at UCSD okay
Nico grunenberg writes um keep up the
great content I hope that the amazing
show on Rogan helps you more with
followers you're incentive was not to
push back and make arguments
commensurate with Rogan's greater
greater than 50% fan base you did not
yield the clickbait on Kurt's Reddit
channel is a bit much well sometimes I
do yeah post on Kurt's Channel when
there's something relevant uh although I
don't have any time to do that lately
but I do thank you Nico that means a lot
to me and yes I didn't you know I I kind
of you know mixed feelings I did write a
Long blog post which you can get on
brian.com under blog about what is it
like to be a guest on Joe Rogan's
podcast it's the most popular podcast
not only currently but in history you
know my podcast into the impossible
podcast rocketed up to number 71 on all
podcasts in the world there's 5,
344,000 podcasts and this one that
you're listening to is number 71 for one
brief Shining Moment and now it's you
know plummeted probably to number 2,700
but it's still in the tops on science
and natural science on Apple and Spotify
and elsewhere so I'm really grateful it
was a very enduring the the fan base so
to speak number of daily listeners went
from you know almost double to nearly
100,000 on the audio alone and I got you
know maybe another you know
10,000 uh subscribers on YouTube so yes
it's incomparable Joe's great I did have
one friend I won't say who is a very
popular podcast you said the most
important thing is not that you got on
Joe Rogan it's when you get on Joe Rogan
a second time
and I'm like come on man like you're
putting a lot of pressure on somebody I
mean the number of people he only had
2,000 shows mine was number 2023 which
is kind of cool it's the only time
that'll ever happen the year of the
podcast number is the
same so you know one of the odds that's
ever going to happen again I am in
contact with Joe we became you know
somewhat friendly um he did offer to um
you know kind he did accept my offer to
to get together on the eclipse of the
son that'll be visible in Austin next
year uh so tentatively we had plans to
get together he did call me a handsome
devil that was pretty nice um but you
know it's not like we you know exchange
numbers since that episode uh he did
mention me by name a couple weeks ago
and a comedian M Mark R I think Matt r
or riy um so we made a little clip about
that um so obviously made an impression
um you know and uh hope to be back I
didn't want to just be a pushover and
just you know kind of a slathering
praise on all the people that come on
whether it's about UFOs or the you know
previous cosmology gesson I just made
the point that unlike Neil degrass Tyson
and Brian Cox and Brian Green and Eric
Weinstein and um I think I was the first
uh experimental physicist to ever come
on the podcast and as such I felt it to
be my responsibility to bring a whole
bunch of demonstrations and experiments
and we did a lot of cool stuff so if you
watch it um it's linked on my website
briank king.com you can watch the whole
thing or clips of it we're chopping them
up putting them on my YouTube channel uh
so they get demonetized instantly but
that's fine we don't do it for the money
we really just want to show the the
universe uh kind of the cool stuff that
Joe and I talked about and yeah I do
hope we get back on uh at some point but
you know was kind of a kind of a uh a
you know a real highlight from this
phase of my life where I've switched you
know from being you know uh purely I'll
say just a professor you know in the in
the work realm to balancing this this
you know kind of I won't say side hustle
because it's more than a hustle it's
something I really enjoy doing I lose
money on it it cost me a lot of money to
maintain the editors and thumbnail
designers and uh audio producers and
that's a lot a lot of money to do that
uh but you know not really doing that
for the money it's a lot of fun to
communicate with people and get to talk
to Great authors and now I'm at the
point where you know I have Nobel
laurates asking me to come on the
podcast um I say no to them no I
don't you know I'm hoping to write a
second volume of into the impossible
think like a Nobel Prize winner at some
point I have ideas for another kind of
Popular Science book with with some
hardcore science like losing the Nobel
Prize was um and my day job is is still
incredibly important to me and
meaningful to me to be a professor to
teach young minds and to get them you
know to a state where they know more
than me and contribute more than I can
uh it's the ultimate leverage in science
and it's our ultimate obligation as As
Leaders as mentors as scientists
professors um and no matter what level
we're at okay Bill Anderson last
question from Twitter before we move to
YouTube I'll have to speed this up or
otherwise it'll be my longest episode
ever Bill Anderson asked what new
technology might be on the horizon to
help us detect at least the big
asteroids that might deal us a death
blow EG with lunar base sensors help
with this uh that's a very good question
there are a lot of um new types of
Technology my good friend Phil Luben at
UC Santa Barbara has worked on laser
ablation and you know blasting these
things with lasers I think a lunar based
laser could help um because you wouldn't
have as much energy wasted going you
know transmitting through the Earth's
atmosphere
and all the challenges with that like
hitting a satellite hitting a pilot you
know in a plane killing birds and these
are real concerns that he has so
certainly putting something on the moon
would do that I think advances in AI is
a huge buzzword you know but it could be
unless it feels like that's not in its
best interest you know it wants the
asteroid to come here I think the
machine learning you know and also in
orbital mechanics that's going to be a
huge boost calculating trajectories
instantaneously and at farther and
farther distances for smaller and
smaller objects maybe even pinpointing
where these things are going to impact
rather than where they did impact postao
post impact like aob is discovered with
these Interstellar
meteor um so I think yeah detecting them
farther out and um and also you know
producing the types of technology to
deflect them via lasers or even
projectiles at a much greater distance
the more the better the sooner the
better and uh you know kind of real life
don't look up scenario could be avoided
so yes bill that's a great question all
right let's move on to YouTube but again
as a reminder not only do I post these
you know kind of take questions on
YouTube and on Twitter and on Instagram
for my guest I try to promote it a
couple days ahead so and so is going to
be on the podcast you know leave a
question for him or her but I also put
up polls and stuff and one of the polls
I had on recently after this question by
Bill Anderson you just read
was you know what do you think is the
biggest threat to humanity and it was
climate change nuclear war asteroid
impact or something else and you know
almost everybody put you know put
asteroids and um a nuclear war above
climate change uh as a de you know as a
as an Extinction inducing event which I
tend to agree with but it was great to
see some of the other you know
selections that people had on there like
artificial intelligence and whatnot so
yeah so do comment on you know polls and
stuff at these various places it helps
me get to know you and what you're
interested in even more okay now let's
switch to YouTube where I took questions
as well all right from YouTube
Wolfenstein or Wolfstein congratulations
Dr King 150,000 Subs my question do you
think the physics Community will ever
realize that physics constants SpaceTime
geometry wave functions must be caused
to Exist by some kind of mechanism and
should we search for that mechanism well
well the answers are no and yes should
we search for the mechanism yes we
should is it a
necessary
categorical that these things must have
been caused to exist wave function let's
just take wave functions or waves in
general for that matter uh
electromagnetic waves are complex
quantities these are Fields
electromagnetic fields discovered by
Michael Faraday or coined by Michael
Faraday who the retor was the proprietor
the Royal Institution where I spoke and
you can watch my talk on the beginnings
and end of the universe on their
Channel um so do they have to be caused
well if you're talking about a physical
mechanism sure electromagnetic waves
complex you know they have an imaginary
and a real part can observe only the
square the modulus square of such
entities same for quantum mechanical
wave functions although for some reason
people think of the wave function s the
solution to the shorting equation is
somehow more mysterious and woo woo than
the way function of electromagnetism but
they're both these complex
quantities they both describe things
that can't directly be observed but the
derivatives of them uh in the case of
electromagnetics or the squares of them
in the case of qu mechanics can be
observed so cause is kind of a loose
term unless you mean you know some kind
of you know first cause like a god or an
you know aristotlean notion of a God or
so forth so uh we should search for the
origin and how they came to be in
existence the constants of nature for
example but to say that they had a value
and selected for a purpose that implies
a teeology that I think is beyond what
physics is capable of of
saying Happy Days 66666 says congrats on
50K well deserved thank you sir or Madam
question what do you think about the
world economic forum and its members
dictating Global practices policies for
medicine and science well I asked this
of Neil Ferguson when he was on uh late
2022 and he told me in his opinion we
shouldn't worry about them uh because
they're really they're this
International Organization this world
Forum um really people get together for
you know this binge of you know kind of
it seems to be
prostitutes and skiing and you know
might be fun for some people
but he said they don't have a Navy they
don't have an Air Force they don't have
any military yes it's true that you know
they'll have Vladimir zalinsky will
speak there uh you'll have Anthony borla
talking about you know vaccines but
would they not be advocating for
vaccines and and for you know um Aid to
Ukraine you know without the world
economic Forum it sounds like you know
there's many many places so he thinks of
it as kind of a Bugaboo a toothless
dragon or
tiger he's not too worried about it
I try to stay out of it um but um yeah
there there obviously you know kind of
seems to be a menacing mendacious group
of individuals uh I think I've had on
only one guest or speaker there that was
um Lawrence kuss I think he used to go
there uh he's not going there anytime
soon although he will be speaking with
me here in San Diego on I believe it's
October 17th at the San Diego Aaron
Space Museum so come see Lawrence and
Brian and conver
ation uh but to my knowledge I haven't
had any other wef um members on but you
know clous call me okay okay uh Rea aand
says congrats for 150k Subs awesome
thank you so much and my question is how
robust and reliable evidence for the Big
Bang do you think there's a tiny chance
of cosmology one day will be taught
without the big bang and if so what are
the implications for physics and our
understanding of reality well um
something like the big bang happened the
question is is the Big Bang the
beginning of time was it really the
beginning of the universe or merely our
observable universe so clearly the
elements were synthesized the light
elements on the upper left of the
periodic table were synthesized in a
very hot dense phase there's leftover
heat in the form of the CNB there are
other indicators of this uh extremely
early phase of the universe that was
very radically different from our
universe today where the universe was a
fusion reactor
for many um you know thousands of years
and then it stopped that's not going
away so that's part of the Big Bang was
there a pro possibility that the
Universe began maybe earlier than the
big bang you know 13.8 billion years ago
with another Universe yes are there
other Big Bangs going on simultaneously
yes that's a possibility so that would
affect our understanding of reality as
uh rais is asking um uh but the
fundamental you know kind of notion
won't be overturned that the Universe
had a hot dense phase that incubated the
first nuclear uh atoms and the PAC table
that's not going away any more so than
you know Newton's gravity of you know
projectile motion went away when
Einstein came along and gave a deeper
understanding of gravity as the behavior
of certain metrics and geometry in space
time as a whole so that didn't go away
it merely got subsumed so to if there is
a bouncing cosm iCal
model then um or multivers that doesn't
mean that the Big Bang phase of nuclear
synthesis and you know the production of
the CMB will ever be overturned in my
opinion and that's only a recent you
know 50 60 year old Discovery Dan K says
congrats love your channel and the Rogan
episode thank you so much Joe Rogan was
a blast um he's asking about the famous
double slit experiment why does the
electron not smash against the wall and
between the slots and how are you sure
that that the electron bounces in the
room until it lands on the detector wall
so double slit you know with electrons
is very
mysterious uh experiment the
consequences of which in some people's
minds lead to things like uh the
Multiverse with
multiple
convergent um paths being instantiated
or realized in different branches of the
universal U you know wave function
there's no evidence for that I did talk
the very first podcast episode that I
ever did for real it was back in 2019
with Sean Carol about his book something
deeply hidden horrible audio you know
grainy video recorded in person though
and that was cool at uh loyal Mar Mount
University in LA but we talked a lot
about that and he admitted that it's his
favorite of all qu quantum mechanical
interpretations as it's called but um
but nevertheless there there's no NE NE
evidence for it in the double slit
experiment yes the electrons you know
take each path and then uh we're seeing
their interference between them as they
behave like matter waves and that was
known about since the de BR you know
wave particle duality hypothesis of the
early
1920s so um so I think it's it's quite
uh it's it's quite astounding it is
amazing that light and particles matter
behave the same way but if you interpret
you know particles as waves uh very
short wavelengths and localized packets
of information then um you can interpret
them as subject to interference
phenomenon the same way that water waves
or electromagnetic or sound waves behave
okay busy Billy b33 says congrats my
question is what are the implications to
our understanding of the cosmos of
primordial gravitational waves are 100%
confirmed to exist well that's the main
focus of my
research uh or trying to understand if
inflation took place or not or if some
alternative uh to inflation took place
so the problem is we can't prove any of
these models we can only refute them and
so you ask later does it have any impact
on Multiverse or cyclic models
absolutely in fact that's the
predominant impact of the discovery if
we do discover gravitational waves it
absolutely falsifies the cyclical models
and it gives circumstantial evidence for
the Multiverse because they are
consequence of the inflationary model
only and with in almost every inflation
model lies the
Multiverse and that we talked about with
Will Kenny who's coming back on the show
soon talk about his his book an Infinity
of
Worlds um the memes of Destruction
longtime listener and good time good
many time questioner even as well
Simon's Observatory aside what future
experiments or tools have you most
excited I am very excited about um
technology uh in many forms including
including artificial intelligence uh and
also uh discoveries that will be made
with telescopes that are complimentary
and different from the Simon Observatory
and those include the Vera Rubin
Observatory the Roman Space Telescope
we're still getting really cool images
from the web telescope I didn't think
that the web T I said this when I was on
Lex freedman's podcast I didn't think
the web telescope images would have the
impact that they have had um merely
because the hobble images were so
spectacular there's really nothing ever
like them and the web images are better
than the Hubble images but they're not
like orders of magnitude better uh in
fact some of the you know claimed
discoveries that seem to refute the big
bang and so forth by by people we've
talked about before um those were
claimed based on the appearance of the
galaxies in the Hubble Deep Field 30
years earlier um so you know I I we are
seeing things in the infrared that we
didn't see with hubbles so that that is
of an you know order of magnitude so to
speak better but it is um you know
overall the images that we're seeing are
um they're they're spectacular and
they're they're quite fascinating uh but
you know maybe I I can admit that I was
probably wrong I didn't feel like they
would have as big an impact as the
Hubble images have had so I was wrong
about that uh but the grace uh Nancy
Grace Roman telescope will be a
phenomenal the Via rubben telescope will
be um stupendous Imaging the whole sky
with you know I think six meter
telescope every single night looking for
um you know transients looking for
Planet 9 looking for barion acoustic
oscillations these are going to be
phenomenal instruments and some of which
will be complimentary to what we're
doing with the Simon's Observatory we
don't only look for gravitational waves
that's just one of about nine different
science cases and speaking of nine one
of the things we're going to be looking
for with the large aperture 6m diameter
telescope in the Simon's Observatory is
the thermal emission from a hypothesized
planet
9 and I'll have a video soon about you
know the time that many times that we've
thought we've discovered planet 9
including by past guest Constantine
beian and others um and how those did
not pan out so look for I'm actually
going to do that as a YouTube short I'm
playing around with different
formats uh ulv O2 asks in a global
Military conflict are scientists from
opposing Nations allowed to still
collaborate on projects or is that
considered treasonist
in essence within that scenario does
scientific progress slow down stop or is
not affected at all I think it does go
from uh it depends on if you're dealing
with two free societies you know
Democratic societies although I don't
believe that two Democrat truly
Democratic free societies have ever gone
to war in the Modern Age um you've had
authoritarian you've had communist
dictatorships had cold Wars but even
during the Cold War in the 19 you know
60s to 80s there there was still um
there was still inter interchange of of
information scientific information
Stephen Hawking going to Moscow in the
in the 70s and 80s and scientists from
the West like zeldovich or from the East
coming to the West like zeldovich and my
adviser Alex pev uh but really it didn't
compare to the fall of the Iron Curtain
when that really you know allowed a
complete exchange of information it was
very difficult during the Cold War I
think during a hot War you know I can't
imagine like
scientists at you know the univers
Moscow State University are really
collaborating with um you know Kiev
Institute of Technology right now I
think that's just impractical but we do
collaborate with people that we have
effectively cold Wars with like you know
China um you know Vietnam and and uh uh
North Korea not at all but um places
even like Iran we have students that
that come and and study but uh but it's
a one-way Street you know people want to
come to to free societies and for
America for all its flaws um is still
the freest best country in the world so
a lot more people come here and so you
know if anything it's it's a challenge
to come here because we're so free and
because we have so few visas to let the
most brilliant scientists come to but
you know I've had students from Thailand
and China and Uganda and uh Saudi Arabia
it's incredible um how very different
societies have ability to unite over for
you know shared passions for science
with technology it's a little trickier
because that could be used to do uh for
military purposes but for cosmology
theoretical experimental um you know
there is exchange but it is limited the
hotter the temperature of the
war okay Willis FZ asked congratulations
o you do well with this media thank you
it's been a real fun ride for me totally
different than anything I ever did
before 2020 and it was probably the only
really good thing to come out of the
pandemic is that I was able to get
access to guests that didn't even know
who I was and I kind of nucleated the
podcast and it's grown you know from one
subscriber back then to 162,000 as of
yesterday okay he asked a very long
question um and so I'll see if I can
summarize this it's about the process of
evaporating black holes by way of haing
radiation um it's a little echoey down
here uh so the understanding of Hawking
radi which is really built upon the work
of Jacob
beckenstein uh was that black holes
could experience radiative processes
they could have net radiation coming out
of them due to what is now called
Hawking radiation which is incredibly um
tenuous very very cold heat that would
be emitted and it would be the
consequence of what are called virtual
photons where you have uh you know
particle antiparticle maybe colliding
near the near the black holes of an
horizon or maybe just nucleating out of
the vacuum is possibility for photons
and their antiparticles which are also
photons to um to be to be present and
typically those photons would you know
annihilate each
other um or cancel out interfere
destructively but if one goes inside the
Event Horizon it can never escape to
combine again with the other one so
these uh then would be left with an
unpaired glove so to speak and that paed
Photon then goes out to uh can go out to
infinity and radiate away energy and it
was discovered that the amount of of
radiation is proportional to the the
temperature is proportional to the uh
surface area of the black hole which is
related to what it's called its entropy
um and that brings in all sorts of other
things like the holographic principle
that normally the amount of um stuff
inside of a volume determines its mass a
or its information storage content which
is related to its entropy via what's
called annoyment entropy but in the case
of black holes the surface area contains
all this information so it's kind of
like the boundary is is a semacam of the
of the bulk um and so anyway yes this
this process is described by beckenstein
and then built the the entropy formula
was really discovered by beckenstein and
then Hawking extended it to the you know
quantum mechanical pair production
annihilation of virtual and real photons
were a pair would be unpaired and the
unpair and the you know one of the
partners could escape to Infinity
constant Pegasus or const Pegasus how
long do you think it will take to use
neutrinos to see past the the cosic
micro background very cool question um
The Cosmic neutrino background there's
actually two of them there's a neutrino
background in the
form of uh the the the elementary
particles that were PA produced and
annihilated uh during the electure week
phase transition and the formation of
the elements in the first nuclei at the
you know 10 to the minus 15 second you
know time scale uh after the big bang
where in that same nomenclature the
inflationary Epoch takes place at 10 to
36 seconds so it's to see past the
cosmic micro background it would be uh
possible using gravitational waves as
we're trying to do because that's passed
in the sense of earlier epochs neutrinos
decouple at an earlier time as well from
the bulk and therefore they would have a
colder black body temperature they would
trace an era instead of being tracing
the era of 2.7 Kelvin they trace an era
of 1.9 Kelvin which doesn't sound like
that much but it's actually you know
could be equivalent to many thousands or
hundreds of thousands of years nutrino
decoupling there's also a relic
background of neutrinos from all the
Supernova events and all the nuclear
astrophysic events in the universe's
Cosmic history and our Cosmic volume and
that could actually be the limit that
prevents us from going deeper when we
look for dark matter because as I've
said many times and it's one of my more
controversial opinions we know Dark
Matter particles exist they're called
neutrinos they don't interact with light
they're weakly interacting they have
mass we know they have mass we don't
know what their mass is exactly but
that's part of the goal the Simon's
Observatory is to measure not just con
strain their mouth so these cosmic
background of neutrinos either the
decoupling
or the uh the nutr that emit from all
the astrophysical processes and nuclear
processes including Supernova events
that could provide a floor below which
is impossible to keep plumbing The
Depths to understand what Dark Matter
exists and that dark Matter's
properties okay uh next question Rob
dealman says congrats well deserved
thank you so much uh thanks for being a
a member of the
Multiverse what do you suspect is our
eras FL fistin uh that's a great
question um uh so fistin was this
hypothesized substance that allowed for
combustion before Priestly and others
described oxygen as necessary ingredient
um so today's fistan I think uh at least
in the physical sciences we may find
that uh you know the detour that we
spent the adventures that we spent you
know trying to to look for super
Symmetry and and string theory and
building ever larger accelerators was a
waste what we really should have done is
built more cosmological telescopes and
I'm not just tooting my own horn I say
this about every type of cosmological
experiment including those that are
looking for signals very different from
what I can detect with my colleagues in
the Simons
Observatory and this ties into the next
question by uh kaduru 43 if you control
the budget for science in the USA what
experiment would you want to do and why
that above all the other options I do
feel blessed to be able to participate
in this experiment called the Simons
Observatory because it it has this you
know enormous budget $100 million budget
plus and we're expanding it it's going
to be about 200 million by the time it's
done there's another experiment called
the CMB stage 4 experiment horrible name
cool experiment which would be like two
or three of these Simon observatories
have a budget closer to a billion
dollars and that really would be the
definitive experiment it would be able
to do um you know basically ultimate
limit on um on the gravitational waves
that could ever be measured you know
with moderate technology it would have
you know tremendous survey of the sky
for things like Planet 9 and asteroids
and deadly you know comets and so forth
because everything that exists in the
solar system gives off heat and our
instrument is the best for detecting
heat maybe make bigger telescope larger
aperture than our large aperture
telescope twice as big maybe higher
resolution and just cover the whole Sky
make tens of them because you're giving
me the whole budget which is you know
not that much and then um try to couple
that with advances in theoretical
understanding and and data mining data
analysis to look for things like yeah
the masses of the elementary particles
the neutrinos that we've never measured
looking for things like Cosmic
polarization rotation and lenen variance
violation all these incredible cool
things which comes into the next
question from someone other than you
7732 I hope that more subs will come
thank you so much whatevers that point
to lenid violation in the standard model
that's a great question we're looking
for a lence v violation um using
cosmological uh photons that travel
across the universe in that they would
have potential for preferential rotation
as their polarization orientation gets
modulated as they propagate through the
universe and uh the question is um you
know kind of how can we
uh what would we say about that what
kind of evidence would we have is is
someone other than use question well uh
we have circumstantial evidence we know
that the electro week interaction is um
is parity violating and a parity
violation on the scale of the whole
Cosmos that implies a rotation of
polarization would violate Lorent
symmetry under rotations because it's
singling out a particular rotation as
the photons travel to the Earth so that
would per you know that would mean
throughout the whole Cosmos you could
tell everybody well set your watch
counterclockwise means the direction
that Photon polarizations are rotating
that would violate theen stabil Len
invariance so that would be incredibly
cool we don't have evidence right now
other than circumstantially that the
weak interaction does violate it and
electromagnetism in the weak Force are
unified in the electro weak Force so we
know they're unified so at some
temperature some energy scale they must
be violated both electricity and
magnetism as well and maybe even gravity
it might be the gravitational waves have
a handedness variation as well that's an
awesome question something that could
come not only from Brian King's dream
experiment when I controlled the US
science budget or the world science
budget get together the world economic
Forum me and klouse and put all the
world's resources into cosmological
experiments stay tuned for that John
Ahern asks a very pressing question if
tin whistles are made of tin what do
they make fog horns out of John that
question
blows okay um made of star stuff
congratulations next stop 500k well
technically next stop will be 200k when
we do the next one of these I anticipate
that'll come in less than a year and I
can't wait uh for that to happen again
you know it's just a number just means
somebody pushed a button with the
subscribe on it but it really does
influence what kind of guests I can get
you know I I almost try to get Ray doio
and his booking agent was like you know
you seem like a smart guy like your
stuff and this is three years ago I had
2,000 subscribers um but you know they
were like it's just not worth his time
and I get that I get asked to be in a
lot of podcasts as well and if you want
me to on your podcast I usually if you
have a small following I'll say sure but
I want you to do what uh people told me
which is you know when you get above a
certain threshold sometimes it's 10,000
subscribers um you know then I'll come
on and I want you to do that because I'm
trying to make it possible for you to
grow your channel your influence so that
um you can make either a living or a
side hustle from YouTube or whatever you
want to
do as you know I've been blessed to have
these great conversations not to make
money necessarily uh but to um but to
get access to the world's most Brilliant
Minds particularly authors and scientist
and and really promote the people that
would otherwise no one would ever know
about having a conversation with you
know Ena visik you know was a condensed
matter experimentalist like who the hell
knows who that is uh she's a good friend
of mine and she's a great guest and
talked about High T high temperature
super conductivity Jorge hirs same thing
you know no one's ever gonna talk to I'm
gon to seek them out but I'm you know
trying to bring them to light to inspire
some young enish or you know some really
cool scientist
um in in the waiting because I think
that'll be um the one of the great
contributions that I can make as an
educator is to broaden the scope of
people and part of that is based on how
many subscribers you have it's the most
public metric I mean imagine you were
building a company and every single
product that you sold had a how much
profit you make or how many people you
know bought this thing yesterday you
know only the largest companies publish
such information because they sell so
many iPhones it's not going to be
embarrassing to them but on YouTube I
put out a video and you know 2,000
people my I did a great conversation
with Ashley Vance who's an incredible
writer you know it did it was it was you
know seen by a couple thousand people
but not like you know if I do something
about aliens that's going to be you know
100 thousand and yet I love the
conversation because Ashley's a phen
phenomenal intellect and you know we
build relationships and we get to know
each other and you know hopefully we'll
meet in person and I'll be able to
promote his stuff in the future regard
regardless of how many views it gets
okay speed things up radio 2712 says
most podcasters are talking about AI but
nobody is talking about nanotech and its
implications so is it possible for you
to host a podcast on nanotechnology and
its future that's a great suggestion I
will take it into uh mind and actually I
am having on a great author by the name
of Chris Miller who wrote the book Chip
War which is about nanotechnology and
Fabrication particularly of of um of you
know these microchips that we rely on
both for peaceful and Military purposes
and you know his book is obviously about
you know the struggles between China and
Taiwan America uh but actually um when
we get you know Advanced
AI uh we can't really do that without
advanced nanotechnology and pushing the
limits of of
Technology um and you know question is
as Fineman said you know there's plenty
of room at the bottom but how do we
access it uh you know quantum computers
not necessarily nanotechnological in
scale uh but you know the combination of
these the current processes to make gpus
Nvidia and so forth does rely on smaller
and smaller features which requires more
and more nanoscale technology so yes
that's a great suggestion Adam pomoy
9463 says would you get a hold of Dr
Kevin new can of Professor of physics of
Albany New York have him come on and
talk about the UFO subject he can even
present his slide that' be a fascinating
conversation I I'm on an email chain uh
with him I haven't really reached out to
him I've seen some of his work um uh and
you know I'm going to reserve judgment
but but a lot of it is kind of you know
presenting analyses of you know of of
the physical properties kind of what we
call kinematic analysis how fast would
this object be moving if it started at
the you know 60,000 ft and descended to
the Sea surface level as a Tic Tac does
in two seconds and what kind of material
strength would that do and what would
that do to a pilot and those are
interesting but um you know those as I
said those are kind of mechanical
analysis at least what I've seen I'm
sure he's done much more there's only so
much time I have I would like to uh you
know investigate more but I'm certainly
open to it and I I have um had the
thought to contact uh Professor nth okay
last one for now is by Ronald Kemp 3952
explain how the Hubble constant was
determined to be a constant then I'll
subscribe to my channel your channel oh
man wow I have to get the sub if I don't
get the sub I'm gonna not get to
163,944 I'll be stuck at 41 for it um
anyway uh so we measure the Hubble
constant to be a constant but it's a
variable constant in that it will change
tomorrow um from what it is today so the
Hubble constant is the current time
value of the Hubble parameter where the
Hubble parameter is the time derivative
of What's called the scale factor
divided by the scale factor so the scale
factor symbol is a of T and the time
derivative is a DOT of T and the Hubble
constant is a do of T over a and that is
um and that number is
defined uh to be when it's evaluated at
today's T time equals today uh as the
Hubble constant so that's how we get it
it's not constant because there is a
force in the universe called dark energy
which may be a cosmological constant
which is causing the Hubble constant to
get larger and larger with time and yet
we can calculate that and um and predict
what it will what it will be based on
the simple behavior of the cosmic
Evolution uh equations the so-called
Freedman equation so given the dark
energy which is an observable that we
have to measure given the matter content
we have to measure and given the
radiation content including neutrinos we
can calculate exactly what the Hubble
constant should be the problem is when
we measure it today with parameters
derived from the cosic microwave
background it doesn't agree with
measurements done by much much later
time Supernova measurements and that's
led to the Hubble tension where there
are two measurements that disagree at
the 10% level one is around 69 and one
is about
72 and our
73 uh and their individual uncertainties
are at the 1% level so you have you have
a a Time rate of change uh that's
differing at the 9% level that's
excluded by each individual uncertainty
by the factor of five standard
deviations so it's quite quite bizarre
and so um yeah we're learning about that
um more and more every day and
experiments like the Simon Observatory
and the work that passed guest Adam
Reese and his team are doing will help
us understand stuff even more e design
time looks like someone I know but maybe
it's not do I like a filter fish no I
don't like a fil the fish I don't care
for any kind of fish to be honest with
you trying to save the oceans and the
supply of fish Stocks by not eating any
fish whatsoever especially Gila fish
which means filled fish what could be
more appetizing than fish gelatinous
filled with with gelatin and some kind
of wheat-based
product okay um Nicholas Bruning says
congrats when do you think you realize
you're wrong regarding the notion of
highly intelligent non-human entity or
entities present on this planet or
proximate well I'd have to see evidence
for that Nicholas perhaps you or someone
else will find it but for now we believe
that there is uh intelligent life on
Earth in many different forms but uh but
not beyond the Earth as far as we can
tell
okay and finishing up last few questions
in this
spectacular thrilling
150k
Q&A and let's see if I can find some
really fresh hot juicy swollen delicious
like
nectarines um here we go last couple of
questions Scott Gallery what are some of
the areas of your career where
engineering overlaps with a more pure
sense of physics and astronomy I'm an
aspiring civil engineer but I'm always
looking for ways to gravitate towards a
thing I love more than engineering well
I guess that's astronomy well I there's
a tremendous amount in
experimental astrophysics where we build
detectors and sensors and cryostats and
building uh really cool literal
figuratively cool instrumentation that
we take to the most interesting places
on and above the Earth so um if you're
interested there's almost nothing better
uh to meld an interest in cosmology with
engineering practices and we do have
civil engineers that we've employed as
contractors at the Simon Observatory
site to make sure the platforms have a
stable source of concrete pads and
compacted Earthworks and diesel fuel
pipes and overspill protection all sorts
of cool things so we have have actual
civil engineers that worked on the
project at least when we were getting it
started so there's a whole range of
things in in astronomy and in cosmology
from even biophysics you know
understanding molecules in space all the
way up to discovering the origin of the
universe potentially and how that
unfolded so cosmology contains all of
these things multiple
multitudes okay last question maybe
Cassie white love to hear more about
your time at Brown University my
understanding is that an institution
vectoring primarily towards medical
science not necessarily she could be
wrong she says but having lived in
around beautiful Providence Campus and
enjoying the fortunate and presumably
wealthy student body attending IA league
university I'm curious about your
experience there I loved that I wasn't
wealthy I'm not you know uh typical I
was a graduate student not an
undergraduate there's a lot of you know
undergraduates a lot of them are wealthy
a lot of them are not um it's very it's
almost impossible to get into as an
undergrad and they let me in as a
graduate student you know from Case
Western where I was an underground which
was certainly not a place of privilege
uh and I had to work really hard there
um and I held my own I was one of the
better students you know the
experimental students and most of the
classes are very highly theoretical
there's only one lab class um in my time
so um it it's it's there are privileged
people there grad school is very
different and um uh from the uh from the
undergraduate population uh but it is
beautiful campus was honored to speak
there as distinguished graduate alumni
in 2022 gave a talk it's on my website
and on their website somewhere how to
think like Galileo to be relevant for
half a millennium I hope you'll check
that out okay there's one uh question I
can't res this Dan Kay a person from the
past you would like to invite on your
podcast I have to say uh it would be my
father my late father uh who passed away
17 years
ago and uh we you know had a very you
know kind of difficult relationship uh
on and off um but I think later in his
life uh he came to appreciate that I was
involved in science as he was and math
uh and we could have you know done work
together but I think you know I tried to
do for many years a Father Day episode
where I had on you know Peter timby who
was my graduate school advisor kind of
like a father to me I had on um um Jim
Simons who's acted like a father figure
at least you know kind of mentor to me
for many years and so yeah I'd love to
have my father on um but you know it's
not possible also you miss the voice of
people you don't really I have a lot of
images pictures of him uh but I don't
have any you know voice recordings you
know he died in 2006 you know a year
before iPhones even existed um so we
just don't have any recordings of his
voice and so it would be really cool to
preserve that for posterity I did that
with my mother I did a podcast with her
uh but it's private not going to share
that uh uh it's kind of like for her uh
for her 80th birthday uh for the family
and for posterity so it was um it was a
treat to have her on and I do hope that
uh that um you know uh you know I won't
miss those opportunities to connect with
people while they're still live and uh I
could have a in-depth conversation but I
I really appreciate that question uh
makes me think of my my father and uh
mostly remember the good stuff and hope
I can be a a good father for my kids and
someday they want to have a podcast and
they want to have subscribers one of my
sons thinks that when he hits the like
button as I urge you all to do um to uh
that he's subscribing to my podcast so
he's like I subscribe to you A lot of
times today Dad it's very cute uh but I
appreciate all of you who subscribed to
this channel I appreciate you
tremendously it gives gives me kind of a
platform it gives me the gravitas to get
great guests on still a lot of guests
will say no still not big enough and I
do feel like we're under subscribed
given how many cool and interesting
conversations we've had and how many
more in the works pitz are Prize winners
16 Nobel Prize winners four astronauts
multiple billionaires um thought leaders
politicians uh mostly you know
interested in connecting minds and and
grow growing the scientific literacy and
uncovering our place in the universe we
only get this brief amount of time to
appreciate and uh I hope that you
appreciate the podcast and the kind of
value that I'm giving back and I hope
you'll continue to give great
recommendations and to share the podcast
with your friends if you're listening on
audio I love to get ratings and reviews
because that's another way a public
metric where Publishers will see it and
they'll uh agree to let Malcolm Gladwell
or you know whoever Mr popularity Miss
Popularity is to come on the podcast but
I also love having unknowns and making
them have a platform of their own
looking forward to many more adventures
together can't believe when I first did
I did a New Year's episode or maybe a
100,000 subscriber pre-episode I was
like oh you know who do you want to talk
to and I was like I'd love to talk to
Joe Rogan because I love to talk to him
about cosmology and teach him what
experimental astronomyy is all about and
I can't believe in you know two or three
months since we've grown 50,000
subscribers that actually did that and
um many more cool conversations to come
stay tuned share the channel like and
comment and do all those cool things uh
because it really helps the mission and
I appreciate you all so much so as they
say to Infinity subscribers and Beyond
and I'll see you in the next episode